Anthony: Hey guys Anthony here for Dnews at the
Imagine Cup
in St. Petersburg with Jing Loon. So you
guys
created something called KITS. Tell me
about KITS.
Anthony: Now what I love is you guys are using a Kinect as well, right?
2: Yup.
Anthony: So this is really interesting. Now tell me a little bit about
where the idea for this came from. Now in
Singapore, if I understand correctly,
everybody spends a little time in the
armed forces right?
2: Yup. Two years.
Anthony: So, tell me about what the cost if this
will be
Anthony: How do you get the precision out of
the Kinect that you need to learn what
everybody has to do?
Anthony: That's very cool. So
you guys you you built this whole
framework that it runs on and you are
planning not just to bring this to the
military that you're planning to bring
it to other areas as well. Can you talk a
little about that?
Anthony: Tell me about Singapore
as a tech community.
Anthony: So how does it feel to be here at the Imagine Cup sort
of seeing
projects from other countries and
other places that may not be as
technologically inclined as Singapore is?
Anthony: You guys did a
great job thank you so much Jing Loon.
Remember we have tons from the Imagine
Cup all week. So many amazing inventions
and so many amazing games as well.
Be sure to check out Rev3Games. YouTube.com/rev3games
to see all those and subscribe here for
everything else from the Imagine Cup.